okay we'll start with uh some homegrown
news here yesterday the daily wire CEO
Jeremy boring posted a trailer to our
next film our first featurelength comedy
which is called lady Ballers and uh many
people have pointed out
that prior to this you know for for
years now many people have been pointing
out um I have certainly not been the
only one that by All rights there should
obviously be a sports comedy making fun
of the Absurd idea that men can compete
in women's sports it's a ridiculous idea
it's an idea that is just begging to be
sazed and someone should do it but but
Hollywood well first of all they don't
make they don't make real comedies
anymore which I don't even mean that as
hyperbole they just they they just don't
make comedies anymore um and uh and they
certainly if they did make one on the
rare occasion that they do make a comedy
they aren't going to make one on this
subject so instead uh we decided to make
that film the film which should exist
and now it does U here's the trailer
watch in a world where women's
sports is being
transformed the daily wire calls foul
with the most triggering comedy of the
[Applause]
Year guys this is serious Sports can be
your pathway to a better life what like
yours please don't steal my catalytic
converter again winning matters it's the
key ingredient and becoming a winner
maybe you should try it some
time are you going to move I am
not let's cut to the chase I know you're
not a woman hey you don't know how he
identifies if you can beat them what do
you know about the US opens for the
global games you want us to compete as
women $5,000 prizes my lover says you're
a great coach back in the day
doing this is the way the world is now
my 8-year-old daughter told me all about
it so a guy can become a girl with no
physical changes at all oh that's called
ginger fluid so I can be a woman on the
court and a man in the bedroom I can't
believe it nice you mean when you're
sleeping yes Coach Alex we can play
basketball we have to get the whole team
back together it's time we're in I'm in
I'm in to play Lady balers M
up like a girl gu what I'm with
her is my truth this is my
truth from Heroes day one of being a
girl
athlete I love being a girl two sheos we
could dominate every woman's sport
running swimming soccer I said sport
Felix
it's ladies basketball Boys Nobody
watches excuse me are these seats
open never mind getting
dunks and tuing
[Music]
Trunks you know she
didn't that's the biggest I've ever seen
on a lady I don't care lady
Ballers one can even be trans aged now
which provides shelix with a wonderful
opportunity to relive all the
experiences that she missed out on in
school streaming exclusively on
dailywire plus December
[Music]
1st now uh a few things there first of
all of of course most importantly uh a
number of eagle-eyed viewers did notice
a certain um quite handsome yet
strangely attired character appear
briefly in the trailer and uh and yes
that character was me this is this is
what I look like in the film let's put
that up just in case you missed it
that's right you know and um I just want
to give some some background on this I'm
not even sure how much of this I'm
supposed to say but here's what actually
happened this is the real this is like
what this is how this this is how this
came about is uh several months ago
Jeremy pulled me into his office and
handed me a script for this movie
without any context whatsoever and told
me to read the script in like an hour
and a half and uh and then after I read
it I would find out what character he
wants me to play so I read the script it
was a great script it was hilarious and
only after reading it did uh was I
informed that um the the idea was for me
to play the most liberal character in
the entire film uh the like the one guy
who's the craziest left-wing fruit cake
is the one they want me to play and
basically it's a character designed to
be the exact opposite of me in like
every imaginable respect right down to
of course as you know I don't uh I don't
like making physical contact with people
I don't like when people touch me but in
the movie The Character is is a big
hugger loves to hug so every you know
it's basically it's really a character
that's designed just to troll me
specifically and uh and so that's what
happens there as for the rest of the
film you know I'm very confident that
it's funny the truth is I haven't seen
it and I've been asking them to let me
see it for weeks and they insist that we
all need to watch the movie together for
the first time at the red car Premier
which is on
Wednesday um because it'll be a fun
thing for the company or something so
I'm excited to see how it all turned out
and uh I'm mostly excited this will
exist now because it needs to exist uh
mocking a thing that
desperately deserves to be mocked and
there's just this gold mine of Comedy to
be found in really on the left in
general but especially with leftwing
gender Ideology Now gender ideology is
horrific and it's evil and it's wrong
and it's uh uh
it's uh disturbing on every level but
it's also eminently mockable and as uh
it was Thomas Moore who said that the
the devil a proud Spirit cannot endure
to be mocked which is why we should
Mock and you know
mocking mockery of evil and I've been
saying this for a long time mockery of
evil uh is a virtue in my opinion is a a
virtuous act and that's what this movie
does and uh also creating great comedies
for people to laugh and have fun is also
a virtue and there's I mean there really
is basically none of those anymore it's
a whole genre that doesn't exist because
even if you're not making a com now we
wouldn't expect Hollywood this is It's
just Hollywood cannot make this movie
they can't make it but uh you would
think that okay they're not going to
make a sports comedy uh you know making
fun of the of trans ideology we
understand that as much as they should
make it but you would think well you
could make some kinds of comedies like
you could have a comedy that that makes
any jokes at all about any subject but
um the fact is that you know Hollywood's
at a point now where they can't do that
at all they cannot create any
comedies so we have stepped into to uh
fill the Gap and you can see it for
yourself on uh Friday if you haven't
subscribed yet today make sure you
subscribe before Friday if you uh
haven't renewed your subscription I
would do all that and make sure you tune
in on uh Friday you're not going to want
to miss it if You' like to see what else
I have to say you can access my full
show by going to dailywire.com or by
going to the Matt wall Show Twitter page
hope to see you there Godspeed